[Music]
um
do
[Music]
welcome everyone here to the table my
name is don jacobs and i'm one of the
elders here that is serving here at the
table i just want to
say thank you so much for joining us i'm
we are thrilled that you are here
um i also want to thank the family that
is joining us online
you guys are very much a part of this
community and we love you very much
um we do have a quick announcement
um we i actually brought in a special
guest to actually do this correctly
okay so last week that last week it was
kind of interesting
this week we're going to do this this
announcement correctly so without
further ado
brittany
well i think this is probably actually
just for the online people because
everybody here
either already has signed up their kids
or doesn't have kids so
um this friday and saturday we are
having
an event for our kids called summer rama
it's a day camp on friday it will start
at 2 and go to eight
and saturday it'll start at ten and go
to four
it is for kids going into kindergarten
through kids going who just
graduated sixth grade so going into
seventh grade and those 6th graders can
choose whether they want to be a camper
or whether they want to be a helper so
it's going to be like vbs style we're
going to have lots of games
some bible lessons some swimming some
some like stations crafts all kinds of
things it's going to be a lot of fun
um so two things
if you have a kid who is either going or
who is going to join us
if you can sign up online we have
on our facebook right it's on our
facebook
there's a link to click on and register
them
and then if you want to volunteer
or if you have a teenager who would like
to volunteer
then you can i'll put a sign up sheet in
the back i forgot to bring it in here
but i'll put it in the back
as soon as i'm done and you can leave
your name and some way to contact you
and i will get in touch with you i think
that's everything
thank you very much for that okay sure i
didn't mess that one up this week okay
so uh next announcement is that
on in on august 8th we are going to be
having a
baptism over at brett's house so this is
a great
it's our first baptism for the table
family
i'm looking forward to that there's
going to be a lot of fun games
just people getting together um some
drinks and all the other stuff so
please please please uh show up there is
going to be also
a baptism class after this particular
service so even if you didn't sign up
for it please pop in
if you didn't have a chance to do that
so just join us
right at the end of this class other
than that i'm going to
start us off with a prayer
lord just thank you so much for this
community
thank you for bringing us all together
thank you for just this community that
we have
all these different people from just so
many different spaces
lord no matter what kind of week we've
had no matter what
where we've been or anything like that i
pray that you just help us to be able to
bring that here lay it at your feet and
just focus
on what you want us to walk away from
this evening with
in christ saying i pray amen
all right thank you dawn
hello and welcome as he said whether
you're here with us in person or online
we're so glad you're here with us it's
been a hot minute since josh and i have
been here so
it's good to be back with everybody um
my name is joe brock this is josh brock
we have gary miner
we're gonna start off with some songs so
feel free to stand
and join in
[Music]
increase in
a us
[Music]
let the darkness
we
seek
[Music]
foreign
let the darkness
[Music]
[Applause]
change the sphere
build your kingdom here
[Music]
you made us
fill us with the strength
let the darkness
[Music]
change the
we
[Music]
in the
is
[Music]
oh
i see you every day
you know how i need
[Music]
break the down crack the
is
i will go where you shine break the
dawn and crack the skies
[Music]
is
know how i need you
i'm gonna move into our prayers of the
people
gotta get a quick drink
[Music]
all right there will be a time where
you can speak out anybody's name that
you want to us to lift up in prayer
and if you're online we have don here
you can just put it in the comments and
he'll
speak it out for you
for the city of saxi texas and for every
city
and community and all of those who live
in them we pray to you
for the good earth that you have given
us and the wisdom
and will to conserve it we pray to you
for those who travel on land sea or air
we pray to you for the old and the sick
for the widow and orphan for the injured
and suffering
we pray to you for the poor and
oppressed
the unemployed and destitute for
prisoners and captives
and for all who remember and care for
them we pray to you
lord we know that you love us and that
you hear us
and so we lift up these names and
situations to you
[Music]
for the names and moments we have spoken
aloud and for those we keep in our
hearts
we pray to you that they may have life
and light
healing and hope peace and a deep sense
of your presence
amen
[Music]
bless the lord o my soul
o my soul
i worship his holy
name
sing like never before
oh my soul
[Music]
i worship your holy name
the sun comes
it's time to sing your song again
whatever may pass
and whatever lies before me
[Music]
let me see
worship his whole
name like never before
oh my soul
your name is great and your heart is
kind
all your goodness i will keep
on singing
[Music]
10 000
oh
[Music]
oh my soul
and on that day
when my strength is failing
the end draws near and my
time has come
still my soul will see
your grace
[Music]
worship his holy name
a great creator thank you that we can
get here and
hang out and sing songs that uh do
something to
our soul the music that flows
through our ears and moves us to do
something
thank you for this community for the
love that it holds
may we take what we gather here through
music and word and
hugs and handshakes out out to the world
to bring your kingdom here christ's name
amen
all right young be seated thanks for
singing with us um
if you don't mind well you can sit but
i'm gonna ask you to stand up again and
shake hands if you're comfortable you're
comfortable
hug if you're comfortable say hi to your
neighbor
and hi to the guys online
all right hey y'all grace and peace
good evening it's super super good to be
with you
and um and i want to welcome all of you
especially
those of you who are new see a few new
faces and uh as well as those joining us
online
we love you all lots you are not
forgotten and
um yeah we i just appreciate you taking
time to
um just be here and to worship god there
is i
say this almost every week there's
something so beautiful about the rhythm
of just coming here and remembering
again
um just who god is and kind of
re-centering
where it's kind of a unique community
that we meet sunday nights which is
interesting
because it really does kind of send us
right into
you know monday and um i
find that really helpful and beautiful
so all to say i hope this is just a
life-giving time for you
and that you find it kind of
re-centering you in christ in that way
so um we are in let's see this is part
three
of our series titled deconstruction
finding god
again and uh i gave that gave it that
subtitle
very much on purpose because um my
thought
really what i've seen kind of in the
culture for those who are um unfamiliar
deconstruction
is kind of a phenomena that um
at one level has always been with the
church in the sense of we've always had
to
rethink um question analyze kind of
received inherited beliefs and wrestled
with them
um we're a protestant church for example
and so
that means like 500 years ago martin
luther did a little bit of that and you
know this is like
not a new thing even in the bible you
see jesus doing some deconstructing
with you've heard it said but i say to
you right and he's like quoting
scripture
and then saying but here's a twist you
know so um
so it's not so much a new thing at
another level though
there is something new in that um just
how widespread it is that people are
really
um wrestling with what we believe in why
is this something you've kind of seen
maybe in your own life or just in the
broader culture like
it's real um and
the way i've kind of framed it in the
first week was that we
we kind of go through this process i
think of construction deconstruction and
then reconstruction
um in in this season of construction we
just kind of
receive beliefs we just take them in i
gave the
example of all the little ones over
there right now right not a lot of
deconstruction going on over there
right they're not like is that really
true isn't that an interpretation what
you're saying like
right they're probably not they're not
doing that they're just taking it in
right and this is at some level this is
something that happened to us all
whether you attended sunday school or
not
um we all just kind of receive certain
beliefs and ideas about
god and the world and what's right and
wrong and
you know your thoughts about church and
um
just all the things christ you know all
the things and so we start
just receiving them and then at some
point for various reasons it could be
because we start to engage with
different types of people or maybe
different kinds of christians
or even people of different religions or
philosophies i mean
that's unavoidable now with the internet
i mean of course like we're bumping up
into ideologies and philosophies and
ways of living that are different
all the time right so it could be just
that that it's like you have that
experience and it kind of jarred you and
you're like oh my gosh i'm like
have questions now. you know so it could
be that experience it could also be um
simply the the experience of of
realizing okay i
i inherited these beliefs and i've i
have them and yet i realize
some of these aren't producing um good
fruit in my life that's sort of a
churchy way of of this metaphor a way of
saying
um basically good results like the the
evidence of the spirit of god
which the bible says is going to be love
joy peace
patience kindness goodness gentleness
faithfulness self-control
right so so what happens is we inherit
these beliefs
and it's not producing love it's
producing hatred
it's not producing joy it's producing
self-loathing right you can see like
once that starts happening
this often leads people to deconstruct
um
and rightly so i say like that's
probably a good sign of like okay it's
time to wrestle here
time to get to thinking like all right
am i missing this have i
have i misinterpreted have i
misunderstood right so
construction deconstruction and then
reconstruction is where we
um hopefully it's not just a destruction
right an explosion of our faith and
beliefs but it's a wrestling that leads
us somewhere new
and um that's really what this series is
about is trying to kind of help us
engage that process well
right to kind of go through those steps
so um all right so with that in mind
the past two messages have been a little
bit of kind of um
getting us ready to go and now we're
really starting with some
some deconstruction uh and really
wrestling with
uh some ideas so like this week it'll be
the title of message is deconstruction
in god so it'll be our image of god
um next week we'll get into like
scripture after that i think we'll do
some hell and judgment
we'll just we're just going for it y'all
it'll be great
um so so this this week though is
um is god and i want to begin with a
text that's very foundational
um in my own theology and really for us
at the table i've even preached on this
like six months ago
um but i'm doing it again because it's
just it's so good
so this is um first john chapter 4
verses 16 through 19.
and so he says this and so we know and
rely on the love god has for us
god is love whoever
lives in love lives in god in god
in them and this is how love is made
complete among us
so that we will have confidence on the
day of judgment in this world
we are like jesus verse 18 there is no
fear
in love but perfect love drives out fear
because fear has to do with punishment
the one who fears is not made perfect
in love we love because he first
loved us in that beautiful
uh i think what we have here is really
one of the just absolute high points
in scripture where the way god is
i use the term imaged it really just
means like pictured right there's a
certain description of god going on in
this text
right which creates an image in your
mind right you kind of see god in your
mind's eye so to speak
um that you get a feel for the character
of god
right and so i think this is really one
of the high points in scripture because
the the way
god is imaged is so um profoundly
christ-like right it just feels so
informed by the life
the the love the um the death the
resurrection of jesus christ can you
kind of see that
even though he's not saying like you
know god is like jesus christ you know
you can
tell actually that's very much in the
background in fact this is how he opens
this book like three chapters earlier so
chapter one
this book starts with chapter one i know
shocking so
in chapter one um he begins with this
kind of description
um he says basically look i'm kind of
paraphrasing but he says look
um i was there i
know jesus like i knew him
uh his exact languages he says that
which was from the beginning
um and there's kind of echoes there of
his gospel that he wrote which is in the
beginning was the word and the word was
with god and the word was
god and some of you might be familiar
with that passage that's he's talking
about jesus
there right so that which was from the
beginning
which we have heard which we have seen
with our eyes
which we have looked at and we have
touched with our hands concerning the
word
of life and then a few verses later he
says in this
this is the message that we have heard
from him
and now we declare it to you in other
words he's saying
like i knew jesus and
this is the message i received this is
what he says god
is light and in him
is no darkness at all
now this kind of begs the question um
well isn't that obvious like of course
like why is he saying this
as though it's a sort of like i don't
know like a revelation
right as though he's it's as though he's
needing to clarify something
does that kind of make sense like the
way he's kind of framing this is not
just like okay so i'm just saying you
know
the thing everyone knows this no he's
kind of saying this as though like
it's a revelation it's like oh my gosh
get ready
i i have i've seen jesus i've
encountered him
and the image of god that i received
from that encounter
was so incredibly beautiful and
different than i expected
that's some of what i'm picking up um
from john
and so we might ask so
okay so why does he have to put it like
that why is he framing it like this
and uh i think that's a key key question
and i really thought of i wrestled with
how on earth to segue to this i had a
richard dawkins quote which i ended up
cutting
um i had all sorts of ideas and angles
here on how to come at this
um because i think basically this is
what i'm going to appeal to
um is if for anyone that's actually like
if you've ever just read through the
bible
my assumption is you probably had a few
moments
where you did this
anyone ever make that face like if
you're reading the bible and it's kind
of like
oh oh interesting it's probably i'm
probably not allowed to say you know
out loud that that seems kind of messed
up but
i'm just going to think it here quietly
but i want to be a good christian so i'm
not going to say anything
um have you had you don't have to raise
your hands if you're someone you're like
maybe um i have
i almost certainly have uh
and it was incredibly it was incredibly
jarring
and um and i mean my goodness it just
it just it it threw me for a bit of loot
which we'll get more into scripture and
things a lot of it next week but even
this message will touch on it um
but i think the the kind of takeaway
that i want you to have
is that um the way
well i'll put it like this there are
some rather messed up
images of god um that
are there in our own text and
this becomes a real challenge for us
because now often we don't so much maybe
see it or recognize it or we kind of try
to skip over it or kind of like oh okay
whatever
um in a way that actually um the church
fathers and mothers did not do they were
very
this was my message actually six months
ago was about a spiritual reading of
scripture this is what the church
fathers mothers did
way back like 2000 years ago was they
would allegorize things that was kind of
their path
to like figure out how do i make sense
of this with jesus um i think it's a
spiritual right and they would give kind
of a
little bit of a different kind of angle
on it but you can see
if you've ever read the bible you know
why they're doing that
because the picture you get is in the
bible is not always that
god is light and in him there is no
darkness what is darkness it means
there is no malevolence no
fury and rage no oh i'm gonna
get you like there's there's he's saying
no there is none of that
god is light and love
right and but the reason he has to say
it as a revelation
is because of um some of these images of
god are a little kind of
uh now again i really wrestle with how
to frame this i'm not gonna go through
and give like a bunch of scriptures
if you'd like me to do that i can we'll
email or something um
but suffice it to say they're there
and i think what happens is
we have these kind of images of god not
all of them
very christ-like and then theologies
ideas about
the rest of life and other people and
church and the world
all flow kind of from that and what it
can lead to
is some intensely messed up stuff
and we don't always realize where that's
coming from
but i think this is why i want to start
with deconstruction in god because i
think if you actually track it back
back back back back it's going to
certain images of god that we have
let me give you an example of a theology
i think ooh it's kind of flowing from
a not so good image of god and then it
gets kind of jacked up this is um
a sermon this is from 1741
uh a while back by jonathan edwards
anyone know this sermon it's a famous
one sinners
my dad knows sinners in the hands of an
angry god
you just know it's going to be good when
it's what would you all have done if i
said well the title of my message
tonight is sinners in the hands of an
angry god and that would have
i think that might have thrown y'all
maybe a little thrown off um
so this um it's well i'll just read it
i'm not gonna read the whole thing i'll
read a portion it'll give you a good i
think you'll get a good feel
um so he says oh and i should mention
though before i do this
jonathan edwards himself was one of the
greatest theological minds this
country's ever produced he's an american
brilliant theologian an amazing
christian so my point isn't to say you
know he's terrible
and bad christian like no he had a lot
of good
but there were certain images of god
that he also held that were kind of
messed up and it led to the worst of his
theology that's my point does that make
sense
um all right so here it is he says the
god
that holds you over the pit of hell much
as
one holds a spider or some loathsome
insect over the fire
abhors you
and is dreadfully provoked his wrath
towards you burns like fire
he looks upon you as worthy of nothing
else but to be cast
into the fire he is of pure eyes
than to bear to have you in his sight
you are ten thousand times more
abominable in his
eyes than the most hateful venomous
serpent
is in ours you have
offended him infinitely more than ever a
stubborn rebel did his prince
and yet it is nothing but his hand
that holds you from falling into the
fire every moment
it is to be ascribed to nothing else
that you did not go to hell the last
night
that you were suffered to awake again in
this world after you closed your eyes to
sleep
and there is no other reason to be given
why you have not dropped into hell since
you arose in the morning
but that god's hand has held you
up it's pretty intense
like yeah um
and
i think you can you kind of see how he's
he's doing a theater he's giving you
theology he's giving ideas about hell
and judgment and such
and can you see how it's if you kind of
track it back there are kind of hints
that that how he images god
right his picture of god um
is there's a certain um kind of anger
there's a certain um
uh almost kind of this vengeance kind of
thing happening does that do you feel
like i'm reading that end or is that
kind of
you can you kind of get that feeling um
so this i think yeah this is probably
problematic
and so here's here's kind of my big idea
for knife your notetaker you can jot
this down
until we heal the headwaters
of our image of god any theology we
proclaim
downstream of that will inevitably fail
to be beautiful or compelling
does that make sense so by headwaters
this is a sort of picture of you know
whether it's a lake or reservoir that
then feeds like a stream
that's kind of the picture kind of the
the headwaters the very the source of
the of our theology is our image of god
and everything kind of flows from there
and so
until we go back and really wrestle with
and and kind of change our image of god
i think we're going to continue to
um and have it you know really look and
sound like jesus
um i think our theologies are going to
continue to really um
struggle so this kind of begs the
question
um okay so why don't we just heal the
headwaters like let's just
let's just do it like yeah why don't
theologians and pastors and churches
and you know church folk and everyone
why don't we just like okay let's do it
let's you know proclaim a god who is
like jesus
and you know we'll just do that um and
so i want to give tonight three reasons
of why i think we really struggle to do
this we really wrestle
um both it could be as individuals and
as the broader
kind of church why we struggle to to
heal the headwaters
so to speak this first one i've kind of
already hinted at but i'll i'll just
make it clear just for a few sentences
give it a little time so reason number
one is that the bible itself
offers images of god that don't always
align
with the character of christ right this
is kind of what i named earlier that
it's
and this really throws us for a loop as
protestants because we have a certain
um understanding of what the bible is
and then and so all of a sudden it
throws us off when it's like wait i have
these images of god from jesus at first
john chapter four
and then i have these others but i'm
supposed to like
is it you know what's how do i do i
can't make sense of this
um and and often when people are
deconstructing or in a season of this
like really
struggling with messed up images of god
that they received
then people will tell them like oh you
just you just need to get back to the
bible
you just need to read the scriptures
right and it's kind of like okay
i mean i get what you're saying because
maybe what they're trying to hint at is
like you know
believe god is love and read the gospels
again and you know
kind of re-center and the true image of
god but
but if you just kind of jump around
randomly um
i mean you might find all sorts of
things about god does that does that
kind of make sense
um so i think that's
again we'll get more into this next week
but that's i think the first reason that
the bible itself it kind of gives us
some conflicting images of god and then
we have to really wrestle with that
um and it throws us off second is that
we create
both and frankenstein theologies
uh this is what i think jonathan edwards
was trying to do
because if you asked jonathan edwards
the sinners in the hands of an angry god
guy
if you said like hey so do you think do
you agree with like first john chapter
four
like god is love you know what he would
have said absolutely
he would have like he wasn't like no
god's not love god is hatred and
no no no he would have said like
absolutely yes
god is love and god
is um angry and
you know there's a whole elaborate
theology god cannot look at sin and
god you know it kind of you can see how
this we kind of try to and so what we do
is that sort of the frankenstein thing
is we try to smash them together
right in the same way frankenstein was
like a composition of
various people's bodies and that's kind
of what we do is we have these
kind of various somewhat conflicting
images of god and we're like okay
we can make this work we can make this
work and what it leads to is a strange
um even the preaching of this can be
very strange because like one week
the pastor can say something like it's a
lot of theological whiplash because it
can you know one week it's like
god is love and then the next week it's
like if you don't repent
god's gonna enjoy roasting you forever
right can you see how these are kind of
and they're like and you're like well it
doesn't really make sense
like no no it does it can work it can
work it's kind of like
um as i've shared some of my own story
in past sermons y'all know
all this is like this is my journey
in a lot of ways i was like the
frankenstein theology i was just trying
my best to hold it all together
oh i was desperate i was just desperate
to hold it all together
and um and eventually
i came to the point because by the way
i'm not if you want to be in a different
place than i
am that's okay i mean there's not i
don't have any expectations if everyone
must agree with everything i say and
everything in this sermon um feel free
to do your own wrestling
but i'll just speak for myself i
couldn't eventually i reached a place
where it just
i couldn't make sense of it anymore um
too much whiplash i remember hearing one
one sermon was i jot this down
oh one one week it was you're created in
the image of god god loves you
and then the next week it's passages
like jonathan edwards
you know you are loathsome insect
you know a spider dangling over like
it's just like oh my gosh i couldn't i
just couldn't do it anymore
um so that's the second we kind of
create these both and kind of
frankenstein theologies were
and it's a little bit nonsensical
especially to an outsider
right coming in like maybe if you've
been raised in it you're like no no it
can work
but to an outsider it's just like i
don't know how to make sense of that
um that's the second third is that we're
afraid of being wimpy christians
uh i'll never forget years ago i was at
a different uh church community
and i was preaching on matthew chapter
the there's a few parables in that
chapter but the closing one is the story
of the
the sheep and the goats um this i've i
adore this passage
um and it's the just a little reminder
so it's the one where
um jesus he's kind of describing a
judgment day type scene
right and he kind of has the sheep and
the goats on either side and these are
metaphors for people types of people
like the sheep are kind of the ones who
love well
the goats you know maybe if you know
anything about goats you know not good
right so
so they're um the people who didn't love
well and he gives this remarkable
criteria
for the basis of judgment that day it's
like oh it's all the people who walked
down the aisle and said jesus
you know nope that's not what he says
instead i mean it's it's a remarkable
thing he says um the the reason because
the
the sheep basically asked like why are
you letting us in and he said
well it's because i was hungry y'all
remember this one
i was hungry you gave me something to
eat i was thirsty you gave me something
to drink
i was a stranger you invited me in i was
sick you visited me
i was in prison you visited me
that's the basis and then they say
predictably like
um we hate to break this to you but we
never
actually saw you or did any of those
things to you and he says what you did
the least of these you did to me
all right and then he turns to the goats
and basically well to the the sheep he
says come into the kingdom
right and then to the goats he says like
depart from me and there's all this kind
of
judgment language you know like to the
the place of you know
um judgment and so i preached this
passage read the whole passage
preached the whole thing talked about
sheep and the goats and the
you know judgment i mean i did the whole
thing and so i finished sermon i
you know kind of somewhat predictably
like the pastor's supposed to do went to
the
to the back door to you know shake hands
as people leave
and uh this one guy he kind of like
he just has the strangest look he had
this kind of sly grin on his
face like he and then he winked at me
and i was kind of like okay i'm not sure
maybe i'm beating hit on i'm not sure
what's going on here
and he um but no he comes over to me and
he puts out his hand and he's like i
wrote it down exactly kind of how he
he put this he said um oh that's right
way to go
he said i thought you might skip that
second part of the passage
the judgment part but you didn't
and i was like okay and he goes
you're not one of those wimpy christians
and in that moment like i
knew where he's coming from i get it and
actually in the years since then
i have now heard from many many people
especially those
coming from kind of hellfire and
brimstone
kind of theologies and communities
that they really struggle because
the thing that's in the back of their
mind as they're kind of trying to
embrace
more christ-like kind of loving images
of god they really struggle because
they're haunted by
the idea that uh
like you know what you're doing like
you're just being a wimpy christian
like you're not willing to go the hard
path
the true path the path of i don't know
whatever it's kind of
anger and judgment or something and
um i
think you know honestly well it's almost
the
the kind of put down is that it's it's
this sort of like okay
you just want a god as the divine santa
claus
you know that's the wimpy christians
they just want you know and so i can
imagine folks maybe even
this gentleman who that day was two
thumbs up to me but maybe
if you heard this sermon he would be two
thumbs down he's a you are that wimpy
christian
and if he were here and i could have a
combo with him i would say well here's
the thing
um i would agree with you if
i were randomly plucking a bible passage
like i just found a random passage
second opinion chapter
27 and i just found like you know just
god is love i'm like oh okay
i'm going to build my whole because i
can imagine their critique would be oh
yeah of course
going to build your whole theology
around
god is love like that's uh huh
we know what kind of christian does that
the wimpy kind
and my pushback would be that look
this isn't plucking some random passage
from the bible
coming back to john chapter 4
this is about jesus
the son of god remember how john opens
he's like i was there i saw him
i knew him i heard him
i heard the way he spoke to people i saw
the love in his eyes
and the message i received from him to
tell to all of you
is this god is light
and there is no darkness in him at all
god is love
and i think what this does for us is it
begins
just to change something for us to shift
something because we realize that god
is even better than we expected him
to be i think that's the message of john
chapter four
god is even better than you thought
and you do not have to be afraid
that's the message you do not have to be
afraid
because god is love
i want to read um this passage one more
time in closing
john says and so we know and rely on the
love god has for us
god is love whoever lives in love lives
in god and god in them
and this is how love is made complete
among us
that we will have the day of judgment
in this world we are like jesus there is
no fear and love
but perfect love drives out fear
because fear has to do with punishment
can you hear there how he's wrestling
with the images of god
fear has to do with punishment the one
who fears is not made perfect in love
we love because he first loved us
and what i want to name tonight is that
is not unbiblical
and that is not frankensteinish
and that is not wimpy religion
that is called christianity
the the worship of christ
and who he has revealed god to be the
god who is
love and so that's kind of the
invitation
for both tonight in this whole series is
just to
start here with our image of god
um let's replace the
angry violent retributive
images of god let's replace them with
christ
let's start there let's heal the
headwaters
of our image of god and you think okay
and then we just throw out the bible
that'll be next week
no no because what we do is
you start with christ you say he is the
center and
then you go back and you re-read
everything and you reinterpret
everything from that
lens
so that'll be next week all right let me
pray for you
lord jesus
we
we are people learning to be centered in
your love
and it can be really hard
because we just continue to be haunted
by
images of you that aren't very
christlike
and so god i just lift up all my
brothers and sisters here
and if if you're someone who maybe you
you're just really haunted by some
really messed up pictures of who god
is ones that don't look in or sound or
feel
at all like jesus and if that's you i
want to invite you just to open up your
palms on your lap
and i want to pray for you specifically
god i lift up these folks
and i pray healing over them
god that they would that they would come
to know not just intellectually but in
their hearts and minds
that they would know that you are love
and that you love
them unfailingly that you are goodness
itself beauty itself
god may you meet them may you heal their
hearts
god heal our images of you
we love you it's in the powerful
life-changing name of jesus that i pray
[Music]
amen
holy spirit come and made us now
we are your church
we need your power
in us build your kingdom
here let the darkness fear
show your mighty hand
heal our streets
[Music]
build your kingdom
refuse to waste our lives
for your joy and price
to see the captive hearts release
the earth the sick the poor
for peace cause
we are the church
we pray revive
this earth
[Music]
church on fire when this nation
back change the atmosphere
build your kingdom here
we pray
thanks for coming hang out with us
tonight guys
oh thank you so guys so much um a couple
quick things
um if there's anything about this um
service that
just resonated with you and you just
feel in need of prayer
i'll be up here after the service if you
just need me to pray for you you'll be
happy to do so
for all of our visitors who are here we
do have welcome cards um out in the
hallway
on a table would love for you just kind
of fill one out we'd like to stay in
touch with you
also there if you're interested and
supporting us financially there's some
um envelopes um also on that table so
you can uh
you know give that away or you even go
online
there's a place to do that from our
website as well
don't forget after the service we are
having our baptism class it's going to
meet
right over here so stick around for that
that's something you are interested in
um also that's the only
oh yeah and then don't forget about the
summer rama so we are if you have
something you are
interested in either participating in or
helping i mean helping out with
volunteers and things like that please
talk to brittany um sign up for
volunteers as well
i want to let you go with this um
blessing
may the blessing of god go before you
may god's grace and peace
us abound may god's spirit
live within you and may god's love wrap
you around
may god's blessing remain with you
always
and may you walk on holy ground amen
amen thank you so much for joining us
and you guys have a great week
[Music]
um
do
[Music]
so